For reasons that I don't really understand, lots of really important statistics start with the letter M.
Today's statistics have been brought to you by the letter M. Here are some of the statistics.
Maximum is the largest value in L, minimum is the smallest value in L,
the midpoint is the average of the max and the min--sort of the halfway
point between the largest value and the smallest value.
The mean is the average of the values in L--we all say mean sometimes or average sometimes
also expected value--basically it means the same thing.
The mode is the most common value in L if there's repeat.
The median is say the middlest number, the middlest value in L--basically the numbers
are that half the numbers are bigger and half the numbers are smaller and that there can be ties,
so we'll have to be a little bit careful how we define that.
But essentially it is the value that would be in the middle of the sorted list.
And all these different notions of statistics all give us a way of taking a really long list of values
and then grinding them together to make a single number that fits comfortably inside of our brains.